what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here today John how are you great how
are you doing wonderful guys today we are gonna
watch for the first time ever Barbarian This is
highly recommended by so many people that's why
we're doing it but before we go into that we got
a sponsor a sponsor that we use so it always makes
for the most natural of Partnerships now if you
guys ever watch any of our horror coverage I think
it's pretty apparent that horror is easily one of
if not our favorite genre in fact some of you may
know my passion is actually in screenwriting and
any script I've ever actually completed is within
the horror genre so yeah Horrors my jam that's why
whenever the sponsor wants to work with us it's
always an instantaneous yes especially because
like I said earlier we already use their service
it's shuttered come on you know it it had to be
shuttered it's Halloween time you get like we
love partnering with these guys if you haven't
heard of shutter which is also on AMC plus let
us be the first people to tell you about it is a
streaming Channel dedicated entirely to horror so
if you're a die-hard horror head it is perfect and
just saying same if you're one of those folks who
waits till October to get some horror movies in
to start up your Halloween spirit it's perfect
for you too you can also use promo code home
h-o-m as a mother e for 31 off shutters annual
subscription they have an awesome selection of
cult classic films to iconic Hollywood favorites
in just about every sub genre you could think
of plus some really cool playlists and original
titles they've got their own Creep Show Anthology
series they have a great documentary called
horror Noir which is all about the history of
black horror as well as an anthology series and
some of their newest film titles include Chloe
okuno's Watcher as well as the new VHS film VHS
99 which just became their most watched movie
premiere ever they also have original series
airing right now including the 101 scariest
horror movie moments of all time and queer for
fear which is all about the history of queer
horror they've even got a little Christmas horror
Anthology you might just see a familiar face and
just saying maybe go check it out everything is
uncut and commercial free and the best thing is
you can save 31 on an annual subscription when
you hit up our special link in the description
box and use our promo code home support the horror
genre and by supporting shutter it helps support
the channel so it's really just a great cycle of
return on on support alright guys let's get to it
Harry what is that wow what a transmission
oh is this like an Airbnb situation oh
that would make sense yeah Modern Day
horror films an idea for spooky airplane now
stay with me I'm running this place I I booked
it on Airbnb like a month ago I booked
a home away that's the other one foreign
look it's unbelievable what am I
supposed to do make love that's
pop some bottles why don't you come inside and
we'll call these idiots uh what a clever way to
capture someone yep is that what's happening
probably to see Bill scars have been taking
notes would you mind pulling up your reservation
confirmation just so I can see it Smart in case
I'm some kind of weirdos broken in here to sleep
yep it's starting to give her attitude you got
to be understanding of the situation man come
on you got to know that you are the threat here
I lady why would you go any further wait till
he does it I know I would have done it outside
like get out oh my gosh yeah it looks right to me
listen I don't know what the protocol is for this
me neither share room get to know each other
here's what I propose why don't you just crash
here no I don't I don't think that's I don't know
you you take the bedroom and I'll sleep out here
on the couch and then tomorrow we'll call these
idiots get our money back free stay for both of us
well I can't believe this this
is such a such a scary situation
there's no way I'm sleeping in the bedroom
while a young lady is sleeping on the couch
blame it on my upbringing but it's not up for
discussion kind of have a thing about clean sheets
nah man sleep on the couch
you'd be closer to the door yeah
what if he's the owner huh
doesn't come across like a
Brooklyn New Yorker it's a fake ID
all these indie horror films have this
yellow lighting you creeper you creep
you know you might want some of this but
if I open it while you weren't here that
um that um I'm I'm I'm sorry I'm rambling
Jesus Christ like you're getting at dude
you're good I thought you wouldn't want any
if you didn't see me open it so I waited
I'm good I looked around for some clean ones
but I couldn't find any I'll be fine yeah
I've slept on Mars you're evil
because you're evil evils in a movie
I thought it was great prove it no one's
seen that movie about the makeshift Brass
Band and there's that scene with the kids on
the rooftop playing the coal train stuff yes
that's great I can't believe he saw that
oh no oh no because I'm actually one of the
founders of the lion Tamers we're looking for new
Spades so I'm here for for a week basically just
scouring this side of town looking for our next
little nest what does that mean Nest hide bodies
is it always the girls who get their hearts
ripped out in these things girls can rip trust me
she's gonna rip someone's heart out some
kind of foreshadowing back up because now
it gets hold on a little aggressive with
the thing but that is how you I was gonna
you are officially situated yeah
I think that about does it laughs
stop looking at each other no leave
sleep there is a couch they need to be
putting gear years I'm so sorry oh don't
be don't be like I can sleep on anything
good night Tess can I keep no you're still
creepy I don't give a [__] man you mean
your old family and all scars are family which are
freaks to be a genre of Skarsgard horror foreign
this is such a bad situation no God
does he murder in his sleep Keith
oh yeah
oh you not wake someone up when they're having
a nightmare like that nope especially a guy
so I'm so sorry I'm just gonna I'm gonna
let you go to sleep did you open my door
no it's a matter yeah
is it the music making me wonder if this could
I don't know what's happening I don't either I
can't tell I can't tell I think we're just as
we're supposed to be playing the creepy music
wow you really can't tell any of that at
night well it was really nice to meet you
yeah no I'm I'm excited I'm gonna call
you tomorrow okay this is gonna be great
huh she got the job it's a happy movie yeah
she kind of looks like Halle Berry a little bit
It's oddly the one nice house on this block yeah
what the [__]
good key control oh go away
come out that house my God
true nightmare she goes to the
bathroom a lot in this movie this
movie really does acknowledge
the human biological process
poster hey
oh my God so there's like someone down here
there must be maybe someone's living in the walls
Google
of course
subtly creepy
damn it
so
that's messed up yep oh my God
that is really creepy
nope
oh my God so like a whole ass tunnel
that's clearly a hidden room lady
yeah but it was just you know
oh oh she's an aspiring document here this is the
equipment I need even the lens they capture with
yep grainy gross
do you have a key I I see here but I can't open
this all right how do we know he's not responsible
for this we don't and I found this hidden
passageway in there was this room and it was there
was a bed and a camera and a bucket so there's
a bed and a bucket and a camera paint a better
picture test you know blood stain on the walls
do you see it yeah okay we'll come back up now
Keith oh come on test test no Keith
this house was built on a slant
just let him die
okay so frustrated
don't go no it's the basement within a basement
this is where you call it cop
come up here Keith no it's a trap
maybe go up and call the cops again first
wow that's creepy
this is a
H what is going on oh Keith if
you are innocent you're a [__]
does Airbnb regret having
agreed to this movie yeah
thank you
now why why did you come down in here
we have to come this way
oh my God what who was that
oh my God Christ
oh Keith was innocent the whole time
I feel so bad I'm so sorry Keith
I was so smart to cast him because you knew
that he was suspective because it's him that was
terrifying she's claimed that you were sexually
aggressive during the filming of the pilot and
she no longer wants to move forward if you're
involved they're going to conduct an investigation
and then decide how to proceed wow I'm going to
suggest that you find alternate Wealth Management
wow you're dropping me too
there's a lot of fascinating against type casting
here what no he's definitely playing a 17 year old
still yep the Plucky innocent 17 year old if
I could just have like a conversation with her
I could probably nip this whole thing in the
bud absolutely not under no circumstances are
you to contact her if I just call her and just
listen to me this is such a weird movie I know
I think they're gonna arrest me I think that
is a very distinct possibility I think that
flying off to another state is not a good
look right now that is true yeah yeah I'm
an owner I'm here to pick up a set of keys name AJ
gilbride476 Barbary there it is what is this snake
the lady underground the property manager yeah
she's the one who posts on Airbnb home away or
whatever she also manages the Overlook Hotel I was
Tess just watching her get her his head slammed
people go to the bathroom in this movie
frequently like real life well someone's
here there's a suitcase and clothes and [__]
we haven't read it well do we know when the last
tenants checked out do I have squatters
man-to-man like real talk like what the
she just took some convincings off that's it yikes
ugh in the beginning she was like oh whatever but
like then we started fooling around more and
then she was down like right [__] really loud
I'm a persistent dude right I'm like I had a Time
and she came around and that's it
that's what happened straight up
okay keep telling yourself that was one
I was like maybe you didn't yeah I know
maybe they want me to think line between
seducing an assault Hi Megan this is AJ uh
I I just want to say that I'm really
really sorry if offended you or
because you know people people can have
different versions the same thing and oh God
with chain air huh good pick
how are you oh great he's gonna get
accused of murder too by the end of
the day I'm gonna get the whole rap sheet
tests all right what would a test password be
oh great throw anyway look no you know
how he landed how many takes did that take
ah great shot I have a gun and I'm gonna come
down there and just open up on whoever I've
seen about 30 seconds all right or you can
just come up here now and I'll let you go
squatting my [__] house Jesus no squatters are a
terrible nightmare scenario
though yeah it's very real
and this is smart enough to
figure out how to open that door
no it's an impressive squatter isn't it
the movie I want to name check but
I'm not going to spoil it for anybody
can underground rooms be
listed in square footage when
this
is freaking cut can be noted
separately in the listing's total area
oh hell yeah yeah [__] do
you even know what that means
bring a few knives he does play this guy
very real yes like I know this personality
oh gross 10 by 12 that's 123 by numbers
the keeps on giving oh [__]
this is like I love this a whole
new definition of a dumb character
oh dear old new kind of dumb horror movie
character this is this is beautifully done
what the [__] is this hello
wow the way they use darkness in here
oh god what the [__]
that is scary yeah
who's there
wow these lenses oh this
feels like a video game yeah
keep counting the square footage yep no
stop peace
did you bring your phone too
getting closer it's getting close ah oh no
jeez
what is happening we're in the past now looks
like it is this the origins what a weird film
actually oh nothing good coverage
but it's not easy and there's so many name brands
to choose from but how do you
know which ones aren't voted
wow this movie is so well constructed it's
inspiring it is yeah I would love to see
the script for this plastic sheets
plastic sheets we have some on seven
diapers some baby stuff it's a bit by
this way come on I'll take you here I
the tape yeah so it must be the dad or that girl
down there yeah what crazy production design
sometimes you can feel the cameraman yeah
like you really feel like you're one with
the camera in this yeah like the the way
they use perspective and this is so engaged
are you in the market this guy's a killer
Martindale Motors will make
sure you walk outside of Wheels
and Martial Motors is the motor city's number one
used car dealership that's super creepy foreign
you look like a Carlos
Richard break man how many creepy people can
you play sorry to bother no bother we've got
some outages in the neighborhood and I'm just
checking to make sure everything's up to par
I'm gonna use this bathroom
foreign
way for him to break back in we're moving Frank
yeah I hate to do it you know but the wife thinks
if we don't do it now we may not be able to
get out this time next year because you know
neighborhood's going to hell Frank
it sure looks like it not even questioning
the Carlos name tag not going anywhere
wow
what wild production
no oh no no
oh okay
oh my God
all she knows how to do is be a
mom this wants you to be baby oh
foreign
what is she look at those
creatures from The Descent
this movie is something else
now would be the time to strike her
oh she's got like some type of
unnatural human strength yeah
come on Tess
oh yeah I knew it no no no
sure drank from the bottle man
oh how the tables have turned Justin Long
yep yep
great damn clever script man yeah
[__] forgot all about that [__]
kick it open
should I close the door
come on oh my God you got this you're so
close you were so close you're so close
you're so close no you've got to be kidding
me hopeless man no or maybe he knows oh yeah
maybe he was actually trying to save her
this whole time but I know she's in there
nerve-wracking and she ain't even the
worst thing that's in there what you
need to worry about you now I stay by the
water tower Escape come on wait wait wait
wait wait wait no no we can't leave him we
have to call the police I ain't got no phone
she will kill him I need to help him and how you
gonna do that ever again she comes out at night
if you want to get going then go I'm back and
don't you be around here when it gets dark
she's got to rip her heart out
what else is there
what's the something that's worse in
there like a feral underground baby
maybe Richard break is still alive Texas Chainsaw
Style how would the baby be worse I don't know
I'm okay if Justin Long dies no no
sure go deeper what choice do
you have how far has she gone
so much square footage
he is alive oh Christ do you have any ID are
you listening to what I'm saying I've been
held prisoner so you don't have ID I don't
have anything I am a woman who has been held
prisoner and has escaped and I'm telling you that
there is a man in serious Danger water okay yeah
good foreign
we're gonna get out of here okay
gonna get out I'm gonna get help I'm gonna
let everybody know what's going on down here
you're saying all the wrong things what do you
want and this is trash I don't know what you want
to pull the string I've had enough of you
you're lucky we don't bring you downtown
to sleep this off in jail sleep this off
she's bleeding where where are you going
please please don't go
my stuff is that guy related to him maybe that
guy was behind the wheel when they drove off oh
my God there's a lot some of those
labels puker blind oh gas station
leftover no choice not a night
what's wrong with you yep
oh
my God yeah yeah
yes
use your windshield wipers yes
damn she does have Richard breaks eyes
maybe it's him and a lady man this is a crime
Patrol between these cars
oh please don't kill Tess I'm so
so he's gonna shoot her please for
the love of God yeah don't do one of
those movies don't do one of those no
no no no no horror movie no don't
do it we've become so far please
come on please don't neither the Living Dead us
now no don't that was just
so frustrating please don't
oh
hello crock of [__] that is [__]
hey hey can you okay okay I'm so sorry
come on we gotta get out of here
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh please tell me she's still there
she's going she's gone she's gone
what are we looking at I
gotta be here somewhere oh
the water tower yeah yeah yeah he used to bring
women down there and then he started making
babies with him and babies with the babies and
you make a copy of a cup oh and you end up with
something like that wow which way to get her help
huh you all need to just sit right here and wait
can't I can't do that this is my fault it don't
matter whose fault it is it does I heard somebody
oh but he's about to he's about to fast up damn
change what I've done I can just try and fix it
and that's what I'm gonna do you ain't gonna
do nobody no help if you go out there and get
yourself killed he wasn't talking about you know
he's talking about something completely rebirthing
did you get news out here how do you know she
can't get in here [__] I've been living in this
place more than 15 years and she ain't never came
in this [__] oh jeez so you give her a reason
no no no no
that is why'd you run away it was
a strong copy of a copy of a copy
barbed wire
you shove the gun yeah
wait for me dude
remember about you did this
you're gone
just the definition of an idiot there's nowhere
to go don't stay by the circus I can get away
we're gonna have to slow
her down no what baby what
you awful awful human being
uh
did you break his fall or her fault
that's what it looks like how would
she have possibly gotten ahead of her I was
like how would you grab and twist but foreign
oh my God oh my God are you okay oh my
God shoot the woman in the head first
I have no time to think panicked sure you
did you started to slip there's nothing I
could do you get it right okay you can be
okay I got you I'm saving you you're okay
thank God
do your worst lady oh buddy wow
whoa she just flips
no let her take care of you
oh
what my baby
oh Bill Skarsgard produced it yeah
sweet well done Bravo it's a good movie
that was a ride there's nothing in the credits
right no it's not supposed to be there's no point
sticking around who cares who cares about the hard
work all the different people who made this puzzle
yeah who gives a [__] yeah no that was uh that
was brilliant that was a brilliant movie that was
so well constructed so surprising I I didn't
know I read all I knew was I or Justin long
and Peter Skarsgard were in this film and that it
was a great fun horror film but uh Bill not your
favorite Skarsgard eater what did I say you said
the Peter's got his bills kept feeling like it was
an independent horror film all right this is Fox
film we had like Disney he said just screwed that
Disney I remember uh invited us to some screeners
yeah we're just gonna go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like a Fox Searchlight so I don't know if
they maybe acquired it later if they threw down
some funding or whatever but yeah it's like the
upper side of Indy no it's a fun movie and it's
really well it handles its reveal as well right up
to the you know the character with Justin Long too
yeah like you because like to me it's like no test
is the start of this movie and test is the [__]
like she was great like I could have watched the
whole movie it it has an interesting game with
the audience because when it's switched to Justin
Long it took me some time by like time in like 10
minutes to adjust because I just wasn't digging
it as much as I like I was enjoying it and I
liked the weird abrupt choice about it and how it
was connecting but I was really just fully locked
in for the movie of them like Bill Skarsgard
and and uh bill right yeah and Bill's cars card
and Georgina Campbell yeah them being locked down
there and then dealing and uncovering it you know
I was on the board for the for the first movie
they were pitching us you know yeah for those
three movies in here and they and what we did was
we we hopped around until they all sort of watch
how they're tethered and watch other all comes
together but I was on board for that first movie
so I'm going to cut to to this other thing
and it has such a different tone it took me a
while because Justin long is it like while a great
actor that Justin long he's a great actor and uh I
thought he nailed this role I was like but it was
really emotionally busted in the test character
yeah absolutely and part of you is like yeah
I would totally have watched the the real time
Thriller of this but I liked what they did I I was
like no I wouldn't have it by the end of it all I
wouldn't have it any other way yeah is my point
I'm getting to is like while it was it took some
time to get on board for it um hey yeah because
I because I could have sworn that test because
I was sold test was dead basically and I I didn't
see any reason she'd still be alive yeah there's
no reason that so the way they handled their it
does a good job at reeling you in and making you
question what is going on and not knowing where
it's going but wanting to see it through to the
very end like you wanted you just you gotta find
out where this is going you know like if I was by
myself I wouldn't be turning this off like this
was a very engrossing film with uh such great
Panache to the way it was executed totally it was
so well constructed and so well thought out it was
one of those movies that I imagined they kind of
shot for the edit because it's you get that Vibe
because the editing is so well calculated
the direction is so strong with phenomenal
performances uh throughout Kate Bosworth is in
this she was a voice and Sarah Paxton like you
know there were some favors in here absolutely
I want Kurt bronhole or the neighbor he's like
a comedian the director played uh a character
he's a writer too of it yeah get that impression
yeah yeah I know exactly how cool yeah it's
not an insult like it's it's just so well
calculated and man what a force to be reckoned
with of a filmmaker my God what else has he done
I'm so curious this is like one of those instant
I want to see everything a first movie there's no
second movie he did Miss March a bunch of TV shows
The Whitest Kids you know movie damn rest in peace
Trevor Moore well there's a dark comedy touch
to this yeah absolutely yeah absolutely a really
strong dark comedic touch to it but yeah trying to
let you say some things from the meantime yeah no
no dominate this conversation no for sure this
was this was a very satisfying and gratifying
ride and and yeah it's one of those things where
it unfolds in a way where it's constantly poking
and prodding you and it's constantly throwing
these it plays yeah on your own suspicions both
of the actors and the circumstances and just the
unfolding of like oh man secret passage like it
seems like it only gets weirder and stranger
but not in a way where it feels like what is
the weirdest thing we can throw at you like there
is a logic and I like the way I like movies like
this that will throw you around and disconcert
you and then by the end you're like okay clearly
there is a logic here and you know clearly you
drew out a linear map of this and then sort of
mixed it up to create the most satisfying version
of The Narrative um but yeah it just creates its
own little world and I'm glad that it ends the way
it does it's so definitive because in that moment
where they're like that's not the worst thing down
there I was like oh I can already imagine how this
might you know set up a sequel in a world where
this is slaughtering the you know independent
horror box office but I like that they didn't seem
to pull any punches or or you know hold any bars
and yeah they create this fascinatingly weird
Venn diagram of you have the immediate physical
Stakes of the situation but then you also have
this weird emotional quality where becoming very
aware of who this guy Justin long is especially
after having all the suspicion surrounding Bill
uh Skarsgard that doesn't prove uh you know
merited as far as we know and then yeah having
this having that play on your experience with it
because with Tess you are so much like no I want
you to survive I want you to endure and I want you
too ultimately escape and with him it is like you
could kill him you could yeah yeah and then when
they get him both together I think that solidifies
a nice sort of Brilliance because it's like in a
way it's a fascinating little debate she's like
you know without the knowledge she's like well I
have to go back and save him and then you know you
have those moments where they are sort of on an
even plane and then you graduate to where he has
the upper hand and ultimately makes the dastardly
decisions and so like there's a great I feel like
this combines The Best of Both Worlds in terms
of one of those like a24 Styles psychological you
know uh thematic horror movies but that also has a
monster element that is you know just as visceral
and icky as you know something much lockier you
know I was reminded of a lot of different movies
in ways where it wasn't like oh here's an homage
to The Descent or parasite or uh any number of
other things but like it seemed to borrow those
kinds of story components but use them in its own
very unique and Bleak way yeah well they're
set up for character wealth especially with
like with tests they set her up really well
as like with the kind of career Pursuit that
she has and she would be someone who is extra
observant yeah who could pick up on things and
kind of figure stuff out so it made sense to me
that she would be able to determine like okay
she wants me to be her baby and then her being
kind of like it's it's a it's it's a really cool
um you know final girl Ascension of coming
into her own strength because you know when
she Witnesses Keith which Witnesses Keith really
smart to cast that was like a reverse psycho kind
of casting or reverse uh or reverse shining yeah
it's kind of like a reverse Drew Barrymore scream
like up here like it's Bill Skarsgard It's gotta
be he's got to be yeah he's always evil I know
not to trust him he's an evil man yeah you
know trigger Pennywise come on everybody's
always a disturbed individual you know like so
you just kind of assume he's gonna be bad and uh
yeah and the way he plays it and I think
him having a a producer um attribute to this
contribution to this probably really clued him
into exactly how he had to do the performance like
no the audience has to be suspicious of him they
have to suspect the best way to experience this
without a trailer I have no idea what the trailer
is so I have no way of telling you of of like like
I'm fascinated with films like this how do you
pitch this how do you Market it I mean the obvious
pitch is you know what if you went to an Airbnb
in some like crazy [__] you know like what
if there was something actual malevolent living
underneath the house that you were at so it's a
it's a solid what-if scenario of you know I could
see that pitch but in terms of like the the Mad
cap surreal weirdness that this movie goes down
and and structurally like I have no idea how you
can bear that to an audience so I I think this is
I think the best way to go into this is as blind
as possible but yeah when she first sees Keith get
murdered you know she's Frozen in her tracks she's
just paralyzed at the sight of it you know and as
much as a lot of us would love to imagine if we
were in a scenario like that we might fight back
or stop it um you know I could think of a couple
of people who would definitely be like no I know
them instinctually they go in probably like that
[__] affects something happened like I know a
couple of people like that is one in particular
but um but I think most of us would probably be
just so fear-stricken by something of a site like
first you're dealing with such a horrific site
you're already in a state of fear based off the
environment you're in and and then you're seeing
something so such a crazy um peculiar Oddity you
know just to destroy annihilating someone in front
of you like you would go into shock yeah like
a lot of us would like you just wouldn't know
what to do and I think that so that her being
so filled with fear is kind of what saved her and
then by the end she fights back and then there is
that like um and they they illustrate her well I'm
trying to get as like I think it's written really
well like it's so easy to look at the directing
and the cinematography which is phenomenal yeah
it's phenomenal but I think it's also the kind
of screenplay I feel can be overlooked because
it's a really well done it's it's it I mean
it's the same director yeah it makes sense
but yeah I think in terms of scripting it so it
makes sense by the direction of what to do with
your actors is so well done because now I'm like
oh yeah that kind of girl who would get a fear
struck in a situation like that and then you see
her by the end when before she pulls the trigger
that there is this quality where she can see like
this this monster is kind of like a Universal
horror monster absolutely 100 yeah you're not this
is not your fault the way you are and why you are
the way you are and I I get it and I feel bad for
you and I feel sorry but you're also like I gotta
Murray yeah yeah it's probably sympathetic
towards your existence though you might not
understand as well because I mean you know you
live feral underneath the house and yeah I love
that Touchstone too because it does seem truly
like it does borrow monster movie Aesthetics and
she pulls Jane air out which is like a Gothic
semi-romantic Horror Story in and of itself and
there is that it's like there's so many great
things mishmashing here because like especially
with you know the woman or whatever she's called
and kind of reminded me of the woman that movie
where you know you have this feral woman but it's
a reverse scenario where she can't speak but she
is the aggressor here and even like it reminded
me of like a found footage movie like wreck like
there's so many things it takes but I think it
yeah it it uses all the Thematic elements just
as much as it does the visual elements of those
things well I think it's a good character thing
because you know a lot of we're we're like cliche
people at like a a a low quality theater shouting
at the screen sometimes in the First Act of
this movie yeah like what are you doing woman
get out of there okay go to the creeper come on
here come the [__] get out of there don't go
in there don't go down four stairs the flashlight
which keeps going further in there what's going on
um you know you're just like shouting at
them uh but I wouldn't it's like while
there's some choices that feel very horror
movie of come on don't be stupid like in
real life whenever I'm in any I've never been
in any like truly horrific scenario I haven't
but if anything presents itself as a Potential
Threat I take every like strong caution possible
you know like I try to become very calculated as
possible very calm but intense it's like I'm one
of those people that when Panic happens like that
I become hyper focused and like let me think of
every scenario use the flashlight record with my
phone I become like this weird machine so I start
thinking that but with Tess I thought was cool was
I under I weirdly was buying into how this was all
progressing you know like with her being in the
house as much as like it's going to be a threat
the way the conversations were done you're like
okay I just think it's a smart man even with
you know because a lot of times music it's you
can put a different track a different type of
musical composure on something and you can have
a different response to any scene so they would
play like spooky scary music with situations with
Keith yeah but you had nothing to fear about the
guy so it's a clever manipulation on the audience
but and it and it's not too much because you are
in her shoes going like I I would be suspicious
yeah but if you play the right music you're
watching a rom-com yeah I can absolutely see the
flip version we're one of charming coincidink and
now we're just in for the weekend and finding
true love yeah who would have thought that this
situation would presented some because when he is
saying there are smart things that are being said
um there's a lot of like bodily fluid stuff
in here like bathroom the pregnancy the birth
the feedings bodily fluid things yeah a lot of
acknowledgment of that which is which I find it's
I can't tell if it's like a thematic intent
because then you go down underground and it's
like reverse Texas Chainsaw Massacre words
like we've been living here since the you
know 40s you know no matter how rundown it
gets just peeing in bottles yeah we don't
have the advantage of the upstairs plumbing
and so I don't know maybe there's some kind
of hidden commentary about poverty in there but
but yeah it does seem like a weirdly intent Motif
throughout the movie it's interesting to see a
movie that I really appreciated the flashback
with Richard break and how they include they
they told you the the origin like you kind of
you picked up on what I mean I didn't think
it was like baby within a baby with a baby
but you got it was pretty it became apparent like
okay yeah it's got to be at least his daughter
in some way right yeah um even if it was a
non-consensual way he's gonna be his daughter and
the the way they handled that where you you see
the flashback and you I've seen so many stories
I've never been to uh Michigan myself I've never
been to Detroit myself you know but in my in my
cozy Los Angeles perspective I everything I ever
see that is depicted in Detroit just looks like
it's just like the worst place to visit right now
and they're always dealing with the worst things
and I see a lot of stories about gentrification
over there and run down neighborhoods and stuff
and it they utilize the backdrop of Detroit very
well and different in a way that I hadn't seen
dumb before especially with the way they handle
the flashbacks of look at this stream beautiful
white neighborhood and here they're going a
neighborhood's going to [__] here we better
get out while we can we better get out it's all
going terrible is it oh my God this looks great
yeah looks like dyllic and the way in the cinema
who was the cinematographer um because yeah the
way they handled the darkness was so well done
and how they utilize it for transitions I was very
impressed with this movie it was very impressive
yeah and it made me think you know because you do
have it it allows you I think the the benefit of
having those logical you know Rowdy in a horror
movie theater kind of responses like especially
at first when they're when he's like have you seen
this area and we're like I mean you know outside
it didn't look that bad and then the next day she
goes out and you're like oh oh yeah I get it you
know I didn't see it last night but today I do see
why you wouldn't feel at all comfortable in this
neighborhood and and yeah like the use of light to
even just mask that you know at first because
it plops you in in a way where you're like oh
nice little house you know quiet neighborhood
Zach cooperstein nope never seen any movie this
guy's done interesting I wonder what the lookbook
on the pitch deck look like for this film that's
a good like what were the films they referenced
for visual aesthetic because yeah there's some
there's some interesting touches here sometimes it
really felt like a video game oh those those like
really wide angle like POV arm shots or that that
that especially that yeah moment with Justin Long
well I think what they what like I said at one
point I think when it felt like the camera was you
were the audience with the camera like sometimes a
lot of times you got to make the audience unaware
of the camera and that actually worked with it's
a it made it more effective to feel like you are
the camera without doing the whole handheld [__]
[__] you know like that's usually what they do
to make it feel more realistic okay yeah yeah and
uh while there's like handheld moments the there's
a lot of the way it was mounted which was kind
of like those subtle David Fincher touches we saw
that wisecrack video forever ago where they talked
about how David Fincher was those subtle moves
he'll move with character movements you wouldn't
even notice it's moving yeah until like someone
points it out to you yeah but it's so subtle
that it like reels you in and and I and I I feel
like that was sometimes happening very you know
apparently but other times it was happening in
ways I felt more subtle well they they made yeah
instead of going like oh gritty handheld which
which they do at times and again lends itself to
some of the sort of like almost found footagey
elements in the more intense moments but I think
they really made a great use of wide angle lenses
to convey that sense of you are there as well as
like really kind of long zoom lenses that allow
you to kind of yeah focus in on the person that
you're you're seeing with a little bit of that
background blur but in a way that still feels like
you are voyeuring in on them like it is you said
voyeuristic I think at one point early on even in
that like City Scene you know where you feel the
safest you still have that quality of like I don't
know something's lurking something's watching and
I feel like I am in the room for it too which
is all the more uncomfortable and it's it's uh
impressive because it is a stylish movie but where
this style yeah doesn't usurp the intent of the
style you know it's it's it's substantial style
yeah yeah yes which is the thing you gotta really
try to aim for these days yeah and especially with
horror like horror is to be like the way they do
horror Horrors this is a great example of why
I love watching horror films because stuff like
this is just the most exciting and it's not like
massive budget you know and I I feel like the way
they handled um the AJ character was smart because
they let you in on like no he did do the deed yeah
did do the the awful thing he's the snake and and
then the way they play with tropes is fun because
you know the second I was about to get really mad
at the movie yeah and they mess with you they mess
with you in the book I think it's so intentional
like they have fun with the audience where you do
where like Tess is shot and I was like you gotta
be kidding me what a bunch of [__] yeah because
it seems so awesome yeah it seems so obvious
that it would happen and and then uh but then
they uh they subverted that expectation and then
even with AJ they did that too where you're like
you're really gonna have a Redemption story for
this guy yeah I love that too because he again
he's so good at playing it that it's a nice
moment in isolation but yeah like I like that
they kept his his troop like when it really
comes down to it you watch him bargain with
himself and you watch who that person's psyche
is author the entire situation oh he's a total
narcissist yeah totally and uh and and then in
the he and then you even see yeah when when he
does go to pick up Tess that he's trying to sell
in other stories bargaining yeah yeah it's it's
a bunch of [__] so I'm like no that's that
is the kind of person this movie you know so I
thought that was really effective and the only
predictable moment the only predictable scare
moment because all the scare stuff really got me
but the only predictable one was when she popped
up behind the homeless guy yeah it was the only
time I was like oh come on that's the most cliche
like it's pretty obvious she can't get in here
yeah look at the way you're framing your shot yeah
it's the only predictable time um I like that
guy too that guy's great and that's another
great subversion yeah of exploring the city of
Detroit you know there's something that felt like
very 70s horror about it uh 60s 70s horror about
it yeah it has well because I think it does yeah
really nicely to blend that sensibility with the
modern style because so much of what you are doing
with the characters is kind of watching them in
mundane moments that are just unfolding you know
just stuff is kind of happening and then you
stumble into uh you know the The Perils and I
think you know it's what's the difference because
you know modernality we don't let everything just
you know kind of sit and unfold quite as gradually
as the 70s movie does but I was sitting there
thinking during that that scene where Justin
long is like is Googling a floor plan and square
footage finances or whatever and he's just kind
of just reading it off and just kind of going over
like Monday and stuff like I wondered how much
improv even there might have been with some of
the lines because you are just sitting there for
and I think that like the bathroom thing kind of
lends itself to that too you're just watching
like regular people stuff for so much of it
and yet it's well lived in by the actors and well
motivated by the situations so you don't get like
the deepest dive into who these people are but
they do feel alive and they do Feel Again present
in a way that's then assisted by all the style
and you know cleansing and stuff yeah I think
everything all around was pretty pretty awesome
I thought this was like an awesome film they like
quickly became one of my favorites slight Place
Beyond the Pines vibe to it with the way they do
the narrative all circling around the history
of this house uh it's like a weird Creepypasta
well I like that too like it's it's it has just
enough little not quite Supernatural but there's
something about like man this is this house just
ever since you know Disney started up his torture
dungeon down there it just seems like a Paul lives
over this house and no good can come of this and
through all this negligence of you know the owners
passing it down this is all allowed to happen
that's a strength of evil Vibe and then yeah she
has this superhuman kind of wiriness that I guess
Supernatural yeah yeah she's crushed by a car yeah
it falls off a water tower it is I guess crushed
by the weight of at least another person so yeah
yeah she's very it was like how would you I didn't
even think a gunshot would would enduring to be
honest yeah like I got to that point but I love
that would be the 80 sequel starts off on the
picks up right after it just gets killed yeah
but yeah she killed her in
the first five minutes yeah
um yeah all right well good parenting
movie guys what'd you think about Barbarian
leave your thoughts down below be sure to
subscribe click that Bell leave a like and
um yeah we will uh catch you all soon
but we'll also shout out some patrons
not gonna make a John boyega joke sharks in the
water with Zachary Barker are you Clive Barker
you know Halloween season might have been better
whatever yeah you get it Irfan chowder hungry
talking wall Clocky Ian's I'm in song High
Glover Jacob nepotism never mind bro fan cops
Alan John Carpenters the Ling Logan Scorsese
Kira from Death Note hahaha ericcon 69 dude
there's a snake in my boot
NYX CK Spanish John Longoria
Gail weathers Ferguson
muhammaduke Sharon won our Texas
Ranger Cliff commonly used Latino name
Charlie Alex Day Master tits John the boat
Andy Ray Liotta backstabber you're crazy
macro tungsten Lauren C biscuit simply
a stoner your highs stop it Joanna Saint
Mod Rogue scroll so Jewish 94 Jason
manzukis Rosie Beatty Kirk the cars
I see what you did there Colleen Phillip Jesus
Smith Jen Jesus Smith the Honda vs blocker
laughs fight round one you gotta
mix it up guys finish finish him
fine just figure out which name was yours
it's on screen you can read well we love
you all happy to shout you all out yeah
thanks for being here thanks for joining
us every month all month hopefully this
went over all right leave your feedback
thank you